HE WILL FIND HIMSELF AT THE
PROCESS.
A WIDE TURN PLAYING THIS YEAR,
PHILIPPE MYE MINUTES.
NO CONTACT. AND A MISS BY JOHAN.
THERE IS A PENALTY LOOKING  FIRY
THE STARS IN OVER A DOZEN FIRES
DEFLECTED WIDE OF THE NET.
>> Daryl: ABLE TO R RN THE OUT
SKIRTS OF THE RINK HERERE PENAL
MINUTECORNER.
DUCHENE.
UP HIGH, CARRIER A TURNS IT OVE.
MICHAEL RAFFL ACROSS THE LINE. S
TO FEED A BACKHAND ACROSS TO
BL WERE IN VANCOUVER.
THEY WERE WITHIN A GOAL.
BOARDS TO KEEP THE PUCK IN THE
ZONE AND ITETS IT HAS TO F HAS
THE CORNER.
COMES LOOSE FORING -- SPRAWLINGF
THE NET.
>> Daryl: THIS TIME IT IS THE
CAPTAIN, LATE I
ESA LINDELL
FEED PERFECTY DON'T GET A
LITTLE BIT OF MOMENTUM GOING
TO GET IN AND
GLENDENING.
ON THE BACK END PUT IT BEHIND
TO LINDELL.
THE STARS ARE PLAYING LIKE IT IS
A MATTERKLINGBERG.
PAVELSKI.
IN FRONT AND HAS
BEEN A DILIGENT NIGHT FOR COLTON